j'ai commencé à 14 ans dans l'atelier de
herbert maire mai et pendant deux ans
était un paradis pour moi de de
travailler près de ce sculpteur qui
était pour moi une véritable idole et je
n'avais qu'un désir qu'un souhait c'est
de lui arriver à la cheville et d'être
capable comme lui en quelques heures de
faire votre buste avec les cheveux les
sourcils et les pupilles georges enclos
est un artiste majeur du siècle dernier
après la guerre ses parents le laisse
faire les beaux-arts il se confronte
alors à l'académisme en 1954 il reçoit
le prix de rome et par à la villa
médicis où il côtoie balthus il partage
enfin sa passion la sculpture
il s'intéresse à l'art étrusque et se
nourrit de ses nombreux voyages avec
mathilde de sa compagne très vite et la
commencer à regarder ailleurs et
l'extrême injurié par exemple l'heure
africaine c'était pour lui les nos cols
et les dogons comme on l'a surtout les
japon oui il s'est surtout donné
kamakura c'était des personnages qui
sont à l'intérieur de soi même c'est
vraiment énorme qui regarde à
l'intérieur mais à la fois dans la
nature selon psa
[Musique]
kamakura dorloter dans l'argile visage
bienveillant
on est face à l'homme universel
l'artiste travaille sur le vide sans
armature à tout moment tout peut
s'effondrer
ce côté projeté il le dit prêt ce qui
fait presque de lentilles sculpture
puisque tout est construit sur le vide
avec donc cette construction qui se
créent au fur et à mesure petit à petit
on n'est pas donc dans une taille qui
est liée à la taille de la masse comme
on peut l'imaginer en sculpture mais
bien au contraire un modelage qui se
construit au fur et à mesure et il le
disait aussi parfois je suis presque
plus proche de pollock que de roda
puisque effectivement le geste était
assez violent
étonnamment alors qu'on ressent une si
grande douceur dans les oeuvres la terre
témoignent du passé profondément marqué
dans son enfance par le nazisme quand en
1992 on lui commandent le monument
aguerris il raconte l'histoire de son
oncle et de sa tante jetés dans un puits
vivent près de vierzon
cette oeuvre j'ai souffert de quelque
chose que je ne connaissais pas qu'est
ce que ça voulait dire 7 qu'est ce que
ça voulait dire le judaïsme
d'où je venais mais ça je me suis posé
ces questions à peu près quelques mois
avant la mort de mon père et j'ai
commencé un travail d'étude j'ai appris
le gérer après à lire l'hébreu g j'ai
travaillé le talmud et j'ai cherché
vraiment à comprendre où j'étais où
j'étais accroché d'où je venais et
qu'est ce que je peux je pouvais dire
j'étais à la limite mal à jour je
pensais après son passé son week-end à
tout moment la catastrophe pouvait
arriver donc comme dit le réussissent
une structure c'est ce concile avait
recommencé avez-vous corps paysage corps
explosent et déchiqueté georges jean
claud à ramasser des bribes d'humains
pour exprimer un cri ou un désir de
tendresse chacun se retrouve dans son
oeuvre
une oeuvre visible jusqu'au 17 septembre
à bourges et à nançay